on aura pas d'eau à la cave parce que
deux ans de suite on a eu de l'eau je
crois que ceux dits glad nous a changé
la vie achevé juste à temps la nouvelle
digue de montesson est fonctionnel
depuis le début de l'année 2000 21
longues de 750 mètres elle a protégé
pour la première fois les habitants de
la crue de la seine les premiers en est
content surtout sont les riverains qui
enfin ont les pieds au sec à montesson
et précédente grande preuve vous aviez
deux mètres dans les rues de vielles
circuler quelquefois c'est même arrivé
en petite un petit barclays les les
caves et landes et les jardins étaient
inondées c'était vraiment terrible
depuis toujours les montées sonné
subissait les assauts du fleuve alors
que leurs voisins de sartrouville était
de protéger par leur propre digue un
prolongement initié par l'ancien maire
de montesson jean françois bayle un
dossier de longue haleine que nous avons
mené avec mon prédécesseur surtout qui
était à l'initiative depuis de
nombreuses années sur ce dossier jean
françois bayle qui a été un élu très
punchy sur ce dossier qui a su être
embêtant et il faut parfois des élus un
peu embêtant pour faire avancer les
sujets débuté en 2019 le chantier a
coûté environ 14 millions d'euros pour
lequel le département des yvelines a
contribué à hauteur de 20% depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années c'est vrai que
c'était un des grands dossiers du
département
un des plus coûteux aussi qui a débouché
aujourd'hui les habitants sont sereins
face à la montée des eaux
d'ailleurs promeneurs et joggeurs se
sont déjà approprié l'endroit qui leur
offre un panorama du fleuve